c'est au volant de cette auto caravane
kenney jones a repris goût à la vie
parmi les jeunes de la rue ce
montréalais d'origine irlandaise qui a
grandi sur le plateau mont royal avait
fait des études pour être missionnaire à
l'étranger mais son rêve ne s'est jamais
réalisé à l'âge de 60 ans et se
retrouvait dans une paroisse bien
tranquille son église était souvent
vides ils se sentaient inutile il
pensait sérieusement ou suicide
vous avez envie d'en finir de me
suicider mais c'est parce que c'est une
maladie
le déjà qu'ils ont la grâce à mon cheval
déplétion son bout de l'aventuré en
fille depuis des années rené alors qu'il
entend à la radio
l'histoire d'un torontois qui vient en
aide aux sans abri à bord de son auto
caravane emballé et se dit que c'est
exactement ce qu'il veut faire avec un
prêt de dix mille dollars
ils achètent ce véhicule usagé à un âge
où la plupart des gens sont à la
retraite
il commence à arpenter les rues du
centre ville la nuit jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin quatre jours par semaine les
jeunes y trouve un abri un casse-croûte
un dépanneur et une oreille attentive
je peux le faire les jeunes me raconte
spontanément
le respect de la
vie privée sur mesure ils se sont
parfois très près de leur détresse
beaucoup de labels jamais que j'ai vécu
alors que je vis parce que là j'ai
encore la déflation
les jeunes ont ce problème beaucoup de
nos jeunes ans probable alors je peu
sympathisé
mais l'aventuré ne s'est pas arrêté là
il ouvre le bangor le premier refuge à
montréal qui acceptent les mineurs avec
leur animal de compagnie un centre de
jour et une école pour que les jeunes
intègrent le marché du travail
le père johns aimait profondément les
jeunes heureux heureux c'est le succès
de mes enfants
ok je malheureux c'est la mort
de mes enfants malgré que j'ai je suis
convaincu qu'ils sont reçus par dieu
même si ce souci même sûrement d'une
overdose
je crois que mes gènes sont des femmes
il préférait le père john tu peux partir
en paix il a préparé sa relève afin que
d'autres prennent soin de ce qu'il
appelle ses enfants brigitte bougies
radio canada montréal